when leaves are turning and starting to
fall and many motorcyclists here in
Germany are wistfully beginning to
mothball their bikes for winter the
industry is already wetting their
appetites for next season the intermont
trade show and cologne is a real
highlight for motor bike and scooter
fans the need for mobility freedom and
adventure is as strong as ever in recent
years the industry has been making
record profits and experiencing
double-digit growth Jared blazer from
the cologne trade fair organization says
the sales have risen more than ten
percent over the past few years
motorbikes and scooters are back in he
says among the younger generation to
have fun some of the top brand models
here are making their world debut like
the latest 1600 GT BMWs most powerful
bike it's very comfortable and ideal for
touring alongside performance safety
features are becoming increasingly
important BMW has now integrated its
intelligent emergency call feature for
cars indore its motorcycles
Carl Victor schaller from BMW motorrad
explains that in the event of a hard
impact in build acceleration sensors
automatically trigger an emergency call
to a BMW call center the staff can speak
directly with the driver by a microphone
and loudspeaker if there's no response
the emergency services are immediately
alerted alum you while roaring engines
can be heard in many stands more and
more people are taking the quiet route
electric motorcycles are booming Gove X
is even resurrecting the East German
Simpson Schwab a scooter 30 years after
it went out of production Thomas greubel
says his electric mobility company has
noticed growing acceptance for electric
vehicles especially for two-wheelers
because they're increasingly convenient
you can charge them up anywhere and so
there are no disadvantages compared to
conventional scooters put in by deloitte
vida muguruza and whether they're the
loud or more the silent type bikers
share a passion for a certain kind of
lifestyle and the ability to live it and
increasingly individual ways no wonder
the customized bike scene is growing big
brands also have their own stands
devoted to this trend there's something
for everyone
uba anger says the appeal of
customization lies and individualization
everybody wants things personalized he
says that the lifestyle effect has
changed the way customizing is viewed
it's not just for getting around anymore
it's a luxury item from any
motorcyclists it is actually a way of
life this season and next
you